this floor is the final floor for the
men's tournament held in AT&T Stadium in
Arlington Texas this floor will first be
offered to the winning team they have
first dibs on it this one is unique it
is what we call the zipper for we start
in the middle it goes from the center
out it's for like a jigsaw puzzle it's a
good analogy if you're just a millimeter
a quarter of an inch off you're gonna
have these shoes your lines won't line
up there's not a 32nd of an inch
difference they're beautiful this floor
is incredibly sturdy and it's tightly
knitted together with the steel and the
systems that we use to pin it and it has
no movement
it's totally solid as a rock the real
outstanding artisan ship comes to life
in the finish of the floor it has to be
properly sanded it has to be properly
sealed and then it has to be properly
applied with the paint it's three
minimum maybe four coats of finish on
top the hardest thing is to making sure
the NTA satisfied with what they pick
and don't have second spawn now let the
games begin you know hit a vest even
with